- In the time of COVID, it's
always refreshing to get out
and see friends, as long
as we can do it safely.
That's why we've created a segment
called the Drive-INterview, get it?
♪ Drive-Interview ♪
- (laughs)The wink, I love you.
Recently, I had a chance to catch up
with Cedric the Entertainer
at our good ole outdoor theater.
Check this out.
(upbeat music)
What's up, Cedric?
- What up, Kelly?
How are you?
Hey, oh, wait a minute, are
we a socially distanced?
Are we six feet apart?
- Oh man, okay, well, I've
been traveling with this.
I think we're good, but like,
let's just check it out.
Now maybe don't touch it,
'cause I don't know how
many tests you've had.
- You're right there, that's already good.
- But we're already good, we're good.
- That's already good.
- It's kind of a little floppy, this one
That didn't work out so well.
- Nice car.
- Do you like drive-ins?
- Yeah, yeah. I love it.
I've loved cars since I was younger.
Now, I used to have cars that
I would work on and like fix,
but you know, I kind of
became real Hollywood,
and then my manicures
started getting messed up.
- (laughs) And then you
didn't have time for it.
- I was like whoa, wait a minute,
I'm not gonna be having dirty nails.
Let me get a guy, let me get a car guy.
- A car guy.
- Yeah, everybody's got a guy.
I got a guy for you.
- Actually, Jay Leno has been my car guy.
- Oh, well then you got
super guy, you got the guy.
- I know, I did his show and
I was like, wait a minute,
so I have this 49 Ford truck,
can you help me out with it?
He's so awesome.
Have you ever done anything interesting
in the back of a car?
I mean, I don't know.
- Well, you know, driving from college,
we used to drive like
two hours from St. Louis
to my little college town
in Cape Girardeau, Missouri.
And one time it was like a group of us,
we tried to play Monopoly
in the car, with the board.
Like nowadays, these
kids got an app I'm sure,
they can just play on an
app and phone to phone.
But we had the board out,
and then whenever my friend would stop
all the houses would
slide off and you would-
- I'm gonna be real with you.
You led with, man in college,
and I thought that story
was going somewhere else,
with the back of a car, and
then you brought up Monopoly.
- Yeah no, no, it didn't get
much sexier than a game of Monopoly.
- It doesn't get much sexier
than getting Boardwalk and Park Place.
- The Community Chest, that
was the most chest we saw.
- That's actually amazing.
So tell me about your new project.
You have a new project
called "The Opening Act"?
- Yeah, "The Opening
Act" is a great movie.
It's really about what it is
to be a standup comedian, how it starts.
I play a character called Billy G.
He's like a old school veteran comic.
And then Jimmy O. Yang is in it
as this young comedian
trying to find his way
and make that choice
from whatever he's doing
in regular life to try
and to like be a comedian
for the rest of his life.
And so the movie captures it all.
And so many great comics
that decided to be a part
of it because of the way
movie is written, so.
- That's a hard thing,
especially when you're not anyone yet.
Now you go anywhere and
everybody was ready to laugh
with you 'cause they
know you're hilarious.
But like in the beginning,
that must have been hard.
- Yeah, no, it is.
It's one of those things where you don't,
you know, 'cause all your
friends are going like,
man, you're funny, you
should do it, you know?
But to go up into a crowd you don't know,
and like have to perform it,
and then do it night after night,
and of course, you're gonna
bomb up there sometime.
And this movie shows all of that.
Well, let's see a little
bit of "Opening Act".
We're at a drive-in, so
let's see a little bit of it.
- All right, check it out.
- All right.
- Find your voice.
You find your voice, your
audience will find you.
That's when you're competing.
- What about you?
- The funny thing is,
when I first started this
I used to think that I
had to make them laugh
so that I could feel good.
But over time, I realized
that I make them laugh
so that they feel good.
It's the best job in the world.
- Oh my gosh, I can't wait.
- Do you remember,
speaking to that, like the beginning,
do you ever remember your
worst gig you ever had?
Well, man, I had a tough
gig with Sam Kinison,
the late, great Sam Kinison, super funny.
Very rowdy-
- Loud.
- Yeah.
- He had a show, I was
in Des Moines, Iowa.
The crowd was there for him.
They were fired up, they were rowdy.
And then they told me to stretch.
The set wasn't ready.
And I was on stage eating it, man.
That was like tough, man.
That was so tough.
- You think that people do that
to other comedians on purpose?
Like with musicians,
you kinda, I don't know,
There's always like other songs,
it's not like a whole thing.
There's no callbacks, really,
like when it comes to comedy.
Do you think he did that on purpose?
- You know, it's Sam Kinison,
I think he was just drunk.
Let's just be honest.
- Well, I love it.
All right, well, hey,
we've got to do this again.
- We do, I love meeting up like this.
You know what it's like?
It's like an old detective
movie where we got like,
I got some stuff,
maybe I dropped some
stuff off in the trunk.
And then you say hey-
- Maybe I got a body in
the trunk, who knows?
- You got the perfect trunk for a body.
- Well, I guess we
gotta meet up for candy.
I'll bring you Twizzlers next time.
- All right, cool, I got the Milk Duds.
- Bye.
(upbeat music)
Thank you so much, Cedric!
We love you here at the
Kelly Clarkson Show.
I Love you so much, you're hilarious.
You can see Cedric's
movie, "The Opening Act"
in theaters and on-demand
starting October 16th!
(sleigh bells ring)
- What!
There's that sound again, y'all.
Let's do this thing!
Ambush Christmas, baby!
(festive music)
(audience cheers)
How about something special
for your cell phone?
I'm just saying.
Case to...
(laughs)
I love you so much right now, Chrissy.
Give it up for Chrissy our Christmas tree!
(audience cheers)
So CASETiFY makes drop-proof
phone cases and accessories
that you can design and
customize on their site.
And everyone in the house seats is getting
a $200 gift card, what!
(audience cheers)